can you be out there trying to make a
sale Don't Judge Me it helps my anxiety
usually the drugs come out at the after
party not at the opening
there's no one here but friends and
deadbeats any collectors coming many
have shown interest any sales the
gallery is going through some changes my
math sucks but I know half of zero is
zero we're a team right we need to find
a new way to deal with the money I
suggest art this thing that looks like a
Smurf wiped his ass with it can sell for
a million bucks
I give you the peace and I'll give you
the money for it and everything will be
clean I need something to sell I will
call my guy have him grab his brushes
and whip something up what's your oldest
name
bang man
The Bag Man I haven't seen you at any of
the events it was under the impression
the gallery wasn't doing well she just
closed this deal on a painting from The
Bag Man at 150
000. that's crazy I'm starting to see
why he has an appreciative audience that
remains under the radar everybody wants
one there's not a waitlist because
there's nothing to wait for I'm not used
to being told
pleasure doing business with you
I need another painting this thing's
supposed to be a front that means low
profile he's a talented artist and when
you make big sales you have the power to
control the narrative you're giving
interviews today Rembrandt
anybody to know about me when you make
art from a truthful place
people find out something about you I
think that money laundering was a crime
but murder
I work with artists trust me
you're another psycho family never leave
you're part of this family now
[Music]
ever
he makes a call I go away forever now I
get you two
he's not going to let you out of this
whatever happens what everybody says I'm
just making art
[Applause]